hi and welcome to the ninth episode of
the Google cloud platform podcast I'm
Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
co-host markman L hey Mark hey friends
sku doing today pretty good happy new
year happy new year to two good start of
the year brand new podcast episode yeah
finally finally ah took a couple weeks
extra but i'm finally back to the United
States and I'm actually very excited
about this episode yeah it's gonna be a
good one I'm pretty happy about it yeah
um before we even thought about what the
main campaign is gonna be yeah let's
start with a cool thing of the week
looks cool thing of the week I like a
lot I'm definitely a big fan of the
command line being especially being a
linux user as well and I really like the
blog post we're seeing today of the top
five power features of the Google Cloud
CLI yeah there are some tricks in here
that I didn't know about that i thought
were particularly impressive yeah
especially if you are a common line
person and especially if you know how to
use arc and sort and all of these little
tools that you can use very well you can
find out really cool stuff quite easily
the nice thing is is actually their
stuff in the Google Cloud a command-line
interface that don't require you to use
likes a dork you can actually tell it to
format stuff in like CSV or Jason just
through the command line options oh
that's right I can push it to like all
sorts of different things it's really
impressive um I've been a long time user
the code completions that you can get
Susie SH and bash but um yeah actually
you got me hooked on CSH and that's how
I discovered the code completion and the
code completion sorry the auto
completion yeah the impressive thing
about it about the auto completion is
that it autocompletes about on many
things yes not only the commands
themselves but also like instance names
and X own zone yeah engines which is
great because I never remember how to
write breeches I never remember with it
with a bash go so yeah or what was my
compute instance name or like stuff like
that yeah
I have 1 i'm gonna add to the list this
isn't mine this is a coworker's of ours
sandeep he came up with a nice wave and
this does this does use ork but we'll
put it in the show notes that literally
lets you pull out what your project name
is from your comp who file I found that
particularly useful when writing like
bash scripts and make files where that
project detail has to be sort of in that
as a as an argument for certain things
yeah that's very nice actually I could
definitely see that as part of some
deployment script or some build far yeah
that's aw yeah now what we're commonly
building you know examples and stuff
where they have to work on either our
project or somebody else's we can't just
hot coda project ID yeah yeah I thought
that I've heart got that many projects
and then when you want to open source
that you're like oh yeah yeah so you're
working on your staging project and you
putting it in your project and you're
like oh man I have to like yes no it's
bad definitely definitely useful we'll
add that little commando dub on the on
the show notes on in addition to our the
link to the today's article ok so that
was our first cool thing of the year
cool thing of the EV actually yeah cool
thing of the year there was that first
cool thing in the year cool thing of the
year there you go and now we're gonna
pass through these amazing interview
yeah I personally had lots of fun doing
it it was really interesting yeah i
think that rom is a very interesting guy
knows a lot about many things yeah and
we're actually going to be talking about
one of the coolest api's that I think we
have club vision API hey graduating
stuff so I say we just go for it sounds
good we are joined today by a very
special guest I'm very excited to have
him here with us today it is ram rama
netten he is the product manager for
Google Cloud vision API thank you so
much for joining us ram thank you guys
thanks for having me on the show not an
absolute pleasure and i did manage to
pronounce your name correctly yes you
did wonderful i like getting that right
it makes me happy so for those people
who aren't familiar with you and what
you do you want to give us a little bit
of your your background and tell us a
little about yourself sure um yeah I'm a
product manager in the Google cloud
platform
I look after some of our machine
learning technologies in particular are
we just released our Google Cloud vision
API it's one of our key products that I
manage and I've spent a lot of time in
the technology space we have been a
variety of different companies put in
the in the Bay Area and in Seattle and
I'm based in Seattle pretty cool so
you've got a long history sort of doing
machine learning type stuff that's right
probably initially started off a lot in
the business intelligence space thinking
about how users can make sense of all
the data they collect and then moving on
to machine learning in the last few
years nice could you give us a little
bit of a general idea of so we have
machine learning and business
intelligence and so on and then on top
of that there's cloud vision API what
what is what is it and how is it related
to machine learning sure uh Google Cloud
vision API is really provides an easy
way for you developers to understand
images right basically the way it works
is we encapsulate a lot of powerful
machine learning models that help and
identify patterns and images and then
apply that to your own images so you can
well it's basically the same technology
that powers things like Google photos
today so in Google photos you are able
to search on your own photos for things
like beaches or things with dog with
photos of your favorite dog and the way
it does that this it basically
understands a pattern in your image for
what a dog is or what the beaches and so
it's able to apply that pattern across
your entire image that so what we've
done in vision API is basically
encapsulate similar models like that and
provide that as easy to use API so the
developer doesn't need to worry about
all the machine learning complexity and
sophistication but really just focus on
hey you're on my images help me
understand what are the contents of the
indigo so it's really built on a
powerful mission Learning Center models
but we provided to you as easy to use
REST API cool no I've definitely become
a big fan of Google photos especially my
my favorite search for some reason I
like looking at grass I just I find it
amazing
like its pictures like it'll give me
like big broad sweeps and at the same
time like close-ups of my dog lying in
grass like just like blade fence and it
just picks it out and it feels like
magic it feels like absolute magic so
that's that's really cool so alright so
what does that kind of translate to so
if I'm a user of the Google vision API I
guess I'm sending it some kind of image
and then it's sending me what does it
send me back what do I get sure
basically what we do is we have exposed
a set of six powerful features like week
based on you can the features that we
provide are things like oneness label
detection so basically if you give us an
image and you choose label detection we
are able to tag an image with a cross of
Y or thousands of different entities
that we recognize and we provide that
back to you with the description of the
of the entity and a confidence score of
how comfortable we think this that this
entity actually exists in your image
another aspect is for example we were
able to do things like OCR optical
character recognition so if you want to
read text in your read the text in your
image we will we can apply the feature
on your image and we are now as part of
the JSON response you will get back the
text that we were able to identify in
the image we all do automatic language
detection or what language the text
belongs to and we didn't provide you a
bounding poly box with the XY
coordinates around where we think the
text exists inside your image so we
similarly we provide other set of api's
like facial detection in which abels
which is able to detect the faces inside
the photo along with the associated
emotions of that face our landmark of be
able to detect wide weather at your
different pearl natural and man-made
landmarks and our logo detection was
able to take product logos inside an
image another aspect is for folks to do
a lot of crowd sourcing of images
basically but their their users upload
images a constant common use cases hey
can I ensure that i can moderate better
images have adult content or violent
content so our safe search annotation
powered by the same technology that
powers our google safe search in the
inmate search up is able to detect
things like whether an image as
adult content in it or whether Lee
Majors violent content in it and we give
you back a club a probability of better
a bucket with it's very likely to very
unlike this that is very cool actually
so because that that's actually so is
that the same models that are powering
the safe search option on google search
that's right so I mean it's it's a
similar set of models but your pup
technology but you can imagine that's
like many of the technology the
published things are on google safe
search to technologies of public google
photos we kind of Mme and yet
encapsulate some of those technologies
as I cuoi API that's really awesome i
can see a lot of people working that
mean actually that FBI and the fact that
they can use it out of the box just like
is this i don't count or not like with a
simple REST API that's that's really
cool yeah that's really really cool no
that's really cool um he talks a little
sort of about face detection eight I did
happen to see and we got a nice demo the
other day from from cows one of our
teammates who helped work on the cloud
vision bot which is a cute little bot
that when it detects your face and if
you smile at it it heads towards you and
if you frown at it it runs away from you
Jeff thought was really really cool
that's right it's a go I'll try with it
but for some reason even though even
though I was smiling isn't ignoring me
that we it the problem was that there
was no Wi-Fi but yeah sure sure you just
are recognizable face oh yeah others not
attractive enough four bucks no that's
that's totally fair enough I'm talking
about face detection now I can see here
that facial recognition isn't supported
do we want to talk a little bit about
that sure I think you know of you know
one of the things that we are focused on
as user privacy and so what we provide
in on the Google cloud platform is just
able to detect faces we don't do facial
recognition so as part of a phase
detection we're able to protect the
faces inside the image and we when we
also detect the associated emotions of
the face by the person is smiling not
smiling we don't store the info out both
the images or the associated information
we return back to the user on Google
servers we'd return it back to you to
the end user so in that way we're
ensuring that you know the user has
control or what
data and associated responses that
sounds pretty pretty reasonable that's
very interesting so basically we're able
to see what is there if there's any face
what are they doing but we don't know
who they are basically that's correct
okay exactly it seems that seems pretty
fair that's it really fair now that
sounds really good so okay so i'm
actually quite curious you probably got
a bit more visibility than we do on this
like what sort of things are people
doing with this like what do you
envisage people like i'm sure you've got
some ideas I mean this seems like one of
these crazy things you could do so much
with yeah you know that there is a wide
ready to use cases I think you know you
know we can demote the initial use case
is really a lot of users wanting to use
label detection to really manage all the
images recreative how do you build
metadata on this large catalog of images
that you may have that's a common use
case that folks want to use it for us a
baby lot of the media companies want to
build large media catalogs or even
companies with build websites are just
to manage what quarter what's the
content of my images another use case is
folks who really want to do things like
on contact moderation right to know in
the case of crowd source content first
of all you still use label detection to
understand what are the contents of the
images but also filter out or you know
be able to modulate adult content and
violent content from crowd so so they
don't share those images with their
broader user community the other use
cases is really thinking about how to
leverage OCR in a variety of scenarios
form like transactional applications
people who want to do things around
reading text form receipts or things and
to being able to use the text from these
images and then do things around and
then do intelligent things based on
those on the text that weekend retreat
from the image and the fourth use case
of course is just is really it is it's a
this is more of an interim more
interesting use case are on image
sentiment analysis you know a lot of
folks have been using text to do
sentiment analysis on what a peak
customers reception areas of their
products but with the power of
combination of both image detection
emotions from the face to product logo
detection people can start understanding
how is my product logo
associated with people who are a the
smiling or sad and what are the other
contents of the image at a certain point
in time now that sounds pretty good yeah
now instead of Kieffer use cases are you
know OCR thinking about extracting text
image metadata management's in made
sentiment analysis and content
moderation yeah no I'm starting to think
about places where I've seen similar
things happen where people have used
crowdsourcing to do this sort of stuff
where you know you get your audience to
flag whether it's inappropriate or tag
what sort of data is inside the cnh
where is now you can sort of look at
doing that automatically which i think
is pretty powerful I'm also just looking
forward to a time where I can just send
a receipt to my expense provider and
it's like oh I know if that is now I'm
gonna sit right here rather than me
having to do all that work so that's
pretty cool yeah that'd be really
awesome yeah so we were talking that
these are basically models that have
been trained by Google and before we had
people maybe like training those models
right is this based on something that we
talked before one of the cool things of
the week it's tensorflow and how is it
be awesome until Express yeah but what's
the relationship between tensorflow I
grew up not google photos google cloud
vision API sure basically a lot of the
you know one of the things is the way of
all these machine learning models
evolved in a recent future to enable are
these powerful scenarios has really
advances in deep learning right so deep
learning enables you really look at
unstructured data whether it's images
videos and really start identifying
patterns in those in there in your data
set and within google we're being
leveraging navy up we're using a
framework called tensorflow to drive a
lot of these scenarios and we recently
opened so start in november and we had
great reception a lot of great feat user
adoption and so internally google we've
been leveraging frameworks like that to
build these models and and what we've
done in under vision API is basically
just put providing wrappers around that
for users to consumers so you can
imagine that people use deep learning
frameworks to build these sophisticated
models and then basically one smalls are
ready to go we're exposing that address
KPS that's that's very cool
who also could you tell us a little bit
more about what what other products i
use tensorflow at Google yep yeah no
weekly inside Google we're using
tensorflow from everything from speech
recognition in the google app right in
ok Google to how we do things are on
smart reply and in boxes as a new
feature we just introduced an inbox that
allows you to intelligently pick common
responses to your 22 emails coming in to
your inbox to how we do image searches
in Google photos one of the interesting
things about tensorflow is its its
ability to adapt to a broad set of
scenarios and also the fact that its
ability to run not just on a single
smartphone but across thousands of
computers and data center so its ability
to scale but you can now imagine some of
these models running on your android
device out of the box right cool
something really interesting that you
mention is that tensorflow is powering
speech recognition and I know that
speech recognition is a very hard thing
to do like I'm always impressed that my
phone understands me yeah if I accent
that's a great dress if that it
understands you and it understands me
and it is sensible it all there that's
really interesting but the the
interesting thing is that it doesn't
necessarily run through an API right
like it actually runs on your phone
that's right so could you this could you
tell us a little bit about how how do we
even do that like the fact that there's
so much information about a model model
but still fit some of your phone yeah I
think that's that's really one of the
things that we were enabling through the
tensile flop framework enables its tits
its ability to support a wide variety of
devices so they you know basically you
can imagine you know people are using
really sophisticated hardware to train
these large speech models and then you
can imagine the power of tensile flows
we can take that model and actually just
enable it to run on a on your mobile
device um you know in overtime you know
this this allows users to think about
more intelligible scenarios where they
drive faster response a more real-time
integrate machine learning real-time
into user workforce right that's really
where we can start driving more
intelligent user workflows where you
know it's just becomes pervasive a great
example is what we're doing that in you
know Google now where we just give you
these flash cards as part of your user
workflow but let's just say tip arise
but Greg what we can do with tensor
flows make make more apps that
intelligent that's really off quad focus
okay so my next question then is since
the robot doesn't didn't recognize my my
smile cuz the well if I was down could
it be possible to have google cloud
vision API as not an API but something
that you're going to install it or is
the model way too big yeah actually uh
you know we do have subsets of what the
API supports on the cloud on on Android
devices we've released recently released
what we call the mobile vision SDK
that's part of the Android SDK where you
know we provide things around some of
the things like around face detection we
provide some of the aspects around you
know some some of the emotion models
that we provided on detective smiles and
we're also providing things around
additional aspects like it's very mobile
so now your focus like things like
barcode recognition that's really really
cool just looking at that now I didn't
even realize that exists that's really
cool that's a good thing about this date
sister it's just on
developers.google.com back vision go
yeah we will add links to that on the
show notes yeah i was saying that's a
good thing about this podcast is every
single episode i learned you I learn new
stuff in exactly now that's really fun
all right wonderful um so I guess is
there anything about like vision API r
tends to flow machine learning that you
wanted to talk about that we haven't
really sort of covered yet no you know
you guys a lot of things I think you
know really where we are is we're at the
infancy of all people are bringing
mission learning into their applications
you know one of the things is you know a
mission learning has really been used a
lot of kind of edge scenarios or
requires a lot amounts of compute and
PhDs to make it functional and really
what we're
looking to do is how do we take this
knowledge make it make it pervasive so
people really start incorporating
mission learning into their everyday
applications and make and make all user
workflows more intelligent at them sort
of bring it down to the consumer level
so it becomes easy to use yeah yeah i
know i've looked at machine learning
just in passing every so often and every
time i do i'm like this is scary yeah
there's there's a there's a very good
course on Coursera yeah yeah I try to go
thread hey spray it gets good intense
when you it's really good though yeah no
that's this lot of good content out
there you know we're and you know it's
it's it I think you know more and more I
think more applications will just I
think people start expecting like you
know people have gotten used to how you
know Google now gets these intelligence
flashcards sort of and people are
getting used to how they can search and
photos and I think it's just going to be
they're gonna start expecting that in
all their other applications over time
and I think you know yeah the more we
can start providing these api's I think
will make it easier for developers to
incorporate that yeah just make it sort
of i can plug in take advantage and just
use and no way that's that's a great
thing about cloud vision API is that yes
machine learning is complicated and yes
you might need to understand a lot of
stuff to train a model correctly yeah
but hey if you know how to do curl and
use a rest api you get you good to go
yep you get to go and you're gonna have
it so that's that's really awesome
brilliant alright well thank you so much
RAM for joining us who really really
appreciate it this is a really fun
interview thank you thanks for having me
um f thanks for having us all right
thank you thank you thank you very much
for joining us ram that was a really
interesting interview i know i learned a
whole lot during that that was great
yeah that was awesome got really excited
about many other projects that i think
we could be out on top of that yeah yeah
yeah as is always with this podcast i
end up listening someone oh my god man
i'm gonna play with that thing it sounds
great um but yeah enough to another day
so okay so before we end this amazing
episode let's go with a question of the
week yes you brought up an interesting
one which I hadn't really encountered
before
if you have a file within Google Cloud
storage but you want to provide
temporary access to it so it's not just
public to Internet you're like I wanted
to be a vailable for like an L or
something like that how do you go about
doing that yeah so there's actually one
way of doing it which is the normal way
and I've seen people trying to do it
it's connect not very useful to do which
is you actually add one email to the ACL
to the echo the accent on access control
list yeah and then after a while you
remove it okay uh feels manual that kind
of works I mean you can do with the
script yes restive yes for that yeah I
kind of worked and you have the lame
enough there's only that person that
will be able to access that access that
file they often that you want so that's
like when you want like a specific user
to be yeah but prom with that the user
needs to log in to do it okay got it so
depending what you're trying to do
depending the kind of abs you're
developing might be a little bit high so
not always the perfect solution then we
have a second solution which is the one
that I wanted to talk about today which
is what we call the sign URLs yep so the
signed URLs it's just an URL that is a
way of accessing that resource there is
only valid for some period of time okay
so it's totally public but you can only
access it for like an hour or a day
exactly so you're gonna be able to say
okay I'm gonna provide access to that
resource but I'm not going to make it
public yeah instead you get the only way
to access the resource gonna go it's
going to be going through that URL yep
and after whatever time you choose one
hour one minute whatever you want yep it
will just disappear okay so that could
be really good for like access tokens or
something like that something yeah I've
personally used it for Google Cloud spin
so that cool demo we had one thing that
we wanted to do is when someone jumps
and we have this image that is how I say
yeah we need to visualize it yeah and we
don't want those images to be public
yeah and we visualized the image for
like five seconds so what we did was to
provide a sign URL that could be valid
for like 30 seconds okay then the
visualizer is able to show it and if
anyone was able to find hakama how get
it I know you find that URL if it's
after 30
seconds sorry too late that's really
interesting yeah okay that's a really
interesting very useful didn't know that
existed that's really really cool yeah
and creating them will add a link to the
to the nodes but it's actually really
simple you can do it with directly with
with GS you do so the Google Cloud
Storage you till you took command yep or
you can also do it through recipe eyes
personally we did it directly on App
Engine you know from App Engine you can
call a couple of APs and that's it it
just works that's lovely ok that's
really handy to know yep so this is the
end of the first episode but before we
actually say goodbye yeah where can I
find you ok so I'm doing a few
interesting things I will be at the
launch hackathon in San Francisco after
that i will be at GDC the game
developers conference also in san
francisco nice and then looks like i
will also be in strada in san jose so
i'm not really leaving California very
much nice you're not even living like
north California no not far away I am
going back to Australia for a bit of a
holiday but that's not work related so
yeah it's slightly more far away yeah
yeah how about yourself well so in a
couple of weeks I'm going to force them
so it's a really cool conference that
takes place in Brussels I'm going to be
managing the go devrim it's gonna be a
good everyone going to be talking there
on yeah it's gonna be lots of fun the
week after that I'm going to pies for
the google that fest nice we're gonna
have a bunch of developers and if you're
gonna be around come come say hi we're
gonna try to organize a couple
hackathons or workshops let's see i'm
still not sure we still put into
planning it yeah but that can be the
first week of march we're in the same
face with like yeah it happened there
it'll be good it'll be good stuff and
then i'm actually really excited about
this one I'm going to Dubai I'm going to
Dubai for gopher con United Emirates are
now wait united arab emirates UAE that's
it that there guy so yeah very excitable
i want you are wonderful and otherwise
if you want to contact us and you turn
on not to be
here in California or somewhere where
I'm gonna be troubling yeah there's a
couple ways they can contact us I can
get us by email at hello at JCP podcast
com the web [ __ ] yeah gcp podcast com
the Twitter JCP podcast the subreddit /r
gcp podcast good job and on google+ plus
JCP podcast and i think that's it I
think that's it yeah if you can't reach
us through one of those then like I
don't ya just let us know but yeah how
do they let it I know that God anyway
thank you so much for being here again
today that was an awesome episode very
excited about the rest of the year a
pleasure as always and I will see you
all next week see you next week bye